- What do you remember
about the first time
you were, like, ever on
stage, like in a musical?
- Oh, I, um-
- [Kelly] Like your favorite one.
- I had the most amazing
dosage of musical theater
at a young age because I had an amazing
elementary school music
teacher, Barbara Ames,
shout out to Barbara Ames.
- Get it, Barbara Ames.
(audience cheers)
- She's actually in "Tick, Tick... Boom!"
I put her in the movie.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that!
- And she plays Jonathan
Larson's music teacher
(chuckles) in the movie.
- I love that.
- I had to, I had to.
- I know, but that's so great,
like a little nugget so
everybody knows that,
like while watching it, that's so cool.
- Yeah, and so she would do something
called the sixth grade play,
she would music direct and
direct the sixth grade play,
and when I was in kindergarten
it was "West Side Story",
and the whole school watched it,
and when I was in first grade
it was "Fiddler on the Roof"
and so by the time you're in fifth grade,
you're like, "What's our
sixth grade play gonna be?"
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- And by the time we got to sixth grade
they ran out of age appropriate musicals
for 12 year olds.
- Ah.
- So we did a very unauthorized,
previous six years worth of musicals,
like 20 minute versions.
So, when I was 12 years old-
- What, did you just pick the best songs?
- We just, yeah, they did like, yeah,
they just picked the best songs
and were like, here's
a 20 minute "Fiddler",
here's a 20 minute "West Side"-
- Like a variety show of
musicals, I love this.
- It was four hours long, my poor parents.
- Oh, my God, all those
parents hated all of you.
(Kelly laughs)
- Hated us, on our wooden
chairs in our auditorium.
But I played a farmer in
"Oklahoma", Captain Hook,
Bernardo in "West Side Story".
- [Kelly] What?
And (indistinct) back up in "The Wiz".
And, who else, a son in "Fiddler",
it was like, just the most
amazing experience of my life.
- [Kelly] What a boot camp.
- When you're 12 and you play Conrad Burty
and you sing and all the girls and boys
have to faint when you sing,
I was like, "I'm doing this."
- "I'm amazing."
- For the rest of my life.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's it, I'm done.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot to like, ask,
that's a high bar to ask of sixth graders.
I like her, Barbara.
- I don't remember
any math from sixth grade,
I remember the sixth grade play.